declara el estado de emergencia tras las
inundaciones en canadá
columbia británica la provincia más
occidental sufrió graves afectaciones
por las lluvias
y
estamos muy preocupados por la situación
en columbia británica millones de
personas están afectadas por las lluvias
torrenciales las inundaciones el
aislamiento forzoso provocado por el
estado de las carreteras vamos a estar
allí con todos los recursos que columbia
británica pueda necesitar
los deslizamientos de tierra destruyeron
carreteras y dejaron aislados a varios
pueblos montañosos el oleoducto que
transporta trescientos mil barriles de
crudo diario desde la provincia de
alberta debió cerrarse temporalmente
mientras miles de personas están
desplazadas las inundaciones y
deslizamientos también cortaron el
acceso al puerto más grande del país en
vancouver interrumpiendo las cadenas de
suministro globales ya tensas las dos
redes de trenes más grandes del país
tampoco están operando en vancouver
algunas ciudades afectadas se encuentran
en zonas montañosas remotas con acceso
limitado y temperaturas bajo cero las
autoridades llamaron a la población a no
tomar riesgos innecesarios
como saben muchas autopistas permanecen
cerradas por las carreteras de sejos
en aliento a todo el mundo a no viajar
solo si es necesario este no es el
momento de viajar con fines de ocio
nuestros servicios de transporte están
afectados y necesitamos asegurarnos de
que estará en funcionamiento tan rápido
como sea posible estamos priorizando el
acceso esencial
a la inundación es la segunda calamidad
relacionada con el clima que golpea a
columbia británica en los últimos meses
un incendio forestal destruyó un pueblo
a fines de junio